ich hasse das ohne witz wenn ich ein
video machen und irgendwo hier so geht
meine mutter lang mein vater keine
ahnung ich hasse es einfach wenn ihnen
wir zu holen oder wenn von da oben
geräusche kommen weil irgendwer über mir
ist so alleine sind sind die halt kannst
du mal leise sein jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video
ich muss euch heute leider sagen okay
was heißt leider
ich hatte halt diese woche nicht ganz so
viel zeit ein video zu drehen ich habe
klausuren geschrieben muss halt nächste
woche auflösen schreibt darf die woche
auch aber halt diese woche musste ich
mehreren als die nächsten wochen glaube
ich glaube ich denke ich mal und
deswegen hatte ich kaum zweiten jetzt
gedanken zu machen was ich mein video
mache es gibt heute einfach dinge die
mädchen also die iran jungs nicht
versteht mich aber hinterfragt pass auf
stellt wieder fragen ich versuche diese
zu beantworten habe hier schon mal
gemacht mit christian halt heute jetzt
alleine
und ja das habt ihr wieder zahlreich
gemacht worum es paar kommentare aus
beantwortet die eine sache die ich noch
loswerden
ich versuche jetzt in den nächsten was
heißt ich versuche ich werde das
schaffen ja ich konnte mich jetzt weil
ich habe eh nicht so viel zu tun außer
für die schule zu lernen
ich konzentriere mich jetzt mega viel
auf youtube das heißt es gibt zwei
videos die woche einmal mittwoch um was
denn das mich kurz überlegen mittwoch
einmal um 15 uhr und samstags bma um 14
uhr so dass ab jetzt hoffentlich im
kalender notiert und jetzt viel spaß mit
dem video
wir haben scheiße jetzt des unfalls wir
fangen an mit der ersten frage und zwar
warum könnt ihr nie das machen was wir
von euch erwarten warum seid ihr einfach
immer eiskalt sowas auch das geht aber
noch weiter dann ist also ein herz und
dann bester boy und dann ich markiert
ich glaube verallgemeinert das ja also
ergibt das eigentlich keinen sinn wenn
du dann nicht markiert weil ich wäre ja
dann deiner meinung nach genauso aber
das halt so du bist wahrscheinlich halt
warum sollten wir eiskalt täglich kann
auch dass das stimmt nicht
ich glaube du hast ein bisschen pech
gehabt das ist das sehr und bin fertig
warum denken jungs männer dass sie
besser auto fahren können oder scheiß
das frage ich mich auch manchmal weil es
gibt natürlich männer die könnten gut
auto fahren und es gibt auch frauen die
keinen scheiß
aber es gibt halt auch frauen die können
gut auto fahren
die können scheiß auto fahren
wahrscheinlich weiß ich heute denken ja
männer können besser so mit technik
umgehen
ihr wisst schon und dadurch kommt das
dann halt zustande aber ich kann es auch
nicht verstehen weil ich glaube ihr
männer können besser einparken das ist
statistisch bewiesen sogar meine ich und
sonst aber generell autofahren ich will
jetzt nicht sagen dass männer besser
auto fahren können
ich verstehe nicht warum manche jungs
mädchen hinterher pfeifen ja das ist
halt so und so manche jungs denken sie
wären kugel wenn sie das machen würden
okay ich bin aufgewühlt aber die denken
sie wäre cool wenn sie ne hübsche
mädchen hinterher falten so vor freuen
dann am besten und dann passt das auch
gut und zwar wie sie wochen die jungs
immer so lange um zu antworten
denkt nicht dass wenn sie halt jetzt
nicht immer direkt nach zwei minuten
antworten sie haben kein interesse an
dir sondern meistens das so die wollen
halt dass dein interesse an ihnen steigt
dass du so denkst auch der antwort nicht
das macht den jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen interessanter es sich so wie
die anderen ja direkt antworten sondern
dann muss man halt bisschen mehr tun
dann stehst du und das heißt jetzt halt
wie gesagt nicht immer dass sie kein
bock auf die haare oder so aber manchmal
halt schon das ist jetzt auch ich tippe
mal du bist auch noch ein bisschen
jünger
warum sie einen fragen ob man zusammen
sein will und wenn man nicht antwortet
sie dann scherz schreiben ja du hast
inhalt mies korb gegeben und deswegen
denkt er sich dann auch jetzt stehe ich
voll bild da ich schreib mal besser
scherzte ganz einfach etwas was mir
auffällt hier streiten sich so welche in
den kommentaren über irgendwann das echt
lustig ich sage euch nicht gegenseitig
fertigmachen hier sollten wir nur
schreiben was euch an jungs so stört das
nächste verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht so und zwar dass sie ihre haare
immer perfekt sein müssen wenn sie jetzt
mal nicht sind trauen sie sich nicht
ihre cap abzusetzen
ich hatte mich da jetzt zurück aber was
ist denn mit euch mädchen ihr geht doch
auch nicht aus dem haus raus ohne euch
hier fünfmal mit denn die rallye würste
oder wie auch immer die heißen durch
gegangen zu sein und was weis ich ohne
schminke meistens auch und soweit also
beschwerde ich nicht bei uns wenn wir
wollen dass wir gleich den meister ja
und jetzt zum letzten punkt das war
wirklich jede zweite frage oder so
bestand darauf und zwar warum sind jungs
in der gruppe immer so cool und stellen
so halten mädchen so floß und warum sind
sein wenn sie dann alleine mit dem
mädchen sind so ja sooo lieb sag ich mal
ich habe das in
letzten oder vorletzten folge
beantworten deswegen würde ich sagen das
war's mit dem video abo nicht vergessen
daumen nach oben geben wenn ihr gehabt
und ansonsten kommt es hier noch schnell
eingeblendet zu dem video wo es darum
geht kommt ihr hier auf der linken seite
eine hier gar nicht zuletzt video und zu
dem video es darum geht kommt die auf
der anderen seite text auf jeden fall
weiß aber würde mich freuen wie sonst
mittwoch wieder nicht vergessen und ich
wünsche euch ein schönes wochenende